hi today i'm going to be talking about
the growing industry adoption
of absorption technologies particularly
in extraction and post-processing
i expect that you might be part of the
canicarius crowd
most likely with a scientific background
a little bit about me
my name is sheldon lotspike and i come
from a completely different world
a world of supply chain management and
maritime logistics
not in terribly technical background
but in the last several years that i've
been supporting
and working with the cannabis industry
specifically with extraction
techs and manufacturers of canvas oils
really gotten a unique exposure to the
industry
and a breadth of perspective on
the general landscape and opportunities
going forward
i feel really grateful for the
opportunity to play a role
in which i can watch science and action
in
processing and in this growing and brand
new industry
there are many unique challenges facing
manufacturers of cannabis extracts
notably contaminants that are present in
the product
scaling activities that are underway to
meet future and current demand
have and will continue to face quality
control challenges
it's important to constantly improve
processing methodology
to meet the need with the smallest
impact to public health
the use of absorbents in the cannabis
industry
are helping to overcome these barriers
facing wider adoption by improving the
quality and consistency of product
so a little bit about the challenges are
the fact that
we are in a transformation into
an industry this comes with scale
and commercialization of the product in
order to meet
just the tremendous demand and curiosity
around interacting with cannabinoids
in this discussion it's going to be
extraction focused
mainly because when we talk about a
commercial product
the general trends are moving towards
edibles
vaporized products or isolates
taken in a tincture and so all of these
are going to be in oil form and thus
extracted from the plant
so what contributes to this is that the
plant has a tendency
to accumulate contaminants it's like a
sponge
this is good for helping it to uptake
nutrients during growth
but can also cause the ability for the
plant to store
pesticides and heavy metals in its oil
producing sites and trichomes
there's a commercial impact on the
prevalence of these undesirable
compounds
and it making its way to the end
consumption product and this is mainly
what
is trying to be mitigated through the
adoption of absorption
some contaminants that can get into the
end consumer product
are unwanted colors or odors heavy
metals pesticides
these are generally not desired by the
end consumer whether or not they know it
so as mentioned in order to accomplish
separating or removing these unwanted
compounds
the industry has looked to start using
adsorption as a solution
absorption simple definition as you may
be familiar the adhesion
in an extremely thin layer of molecules
such as
in liquids to the surfaces of solid
bodies or liquids which with
they are in contact a practical example
of this would be like a brita filter
carbon filtration is a form is an
absorption
process in which the water is coming
through
and you're holding back unwanted
elements which are known to be negative
for your health
with cannabis oil extraction the
absorption process is quite similar
in the sense that you're going after
known quantities which you don't want
there to be there
and you're using a targeted process in
order to pull that out
as we start to kind of dive deeper into
the issue of what is facing extractors
it's important to start with the
regulatory environment
at a federal level in the united states
marijuana which is defined as the
psychoactive dried resinous flower buds
and leaves of the female
hemp or cannabis plant cannabis sativa
or cannabis indica
that contain high levels of thc and are
smoke vaped ingested
especially for their intoxicating effect
so marijuana is a schedule one drug
according to the dea which is defined as
a substance with no currently
accepted medical use and a potential for
abuse
despite this potential for abuse and
these concerns from regulatory
agencies many many consumers
have engaged with their state approved
programs
and are trying cannabis and there are
many new entrances
into experimenting with cannabinoids
so you have marijuana at the federal
level and
hemp and hemp isn't some industry which
has been around for a long long time
it was really only made fully legal with
the passage of the 2018
farm bill which authorized the
cultivation
of industrial hemp which is defined as
the plant cannabis
tiva l and any part of that plant
whether growing or not with a delta nine
tetrahydrocannal or delta nine thc
concentration of not more than point
three percent on a dry weight basis
with the federal level you have
marijuana
and hemp and then even in
legal marijuana states you have a
continued complexity of
state and city regulations
it's good for new markets that they can
learn from previously
legalized markets about lessons learned
and also the approaches taken
but at the end of the day municipalities
are still figuring it out and
kind of still learning what works
with rapid growth which is caused by
interest from the general public and
demand for cannabinoids to be
accessible there is a need for
r d more consumers are going to be more
regulation
as a wider pool of people that are
consuming cannabis
are going to be less educated and thus
you need to have more stringent
production requirements
in order to develop this it needs time a
tremendous amount of time in order to
learn and experiment and it's also very
capital intensive process
one of the elements that also
complicates this
is the various rules that actually
provision for
research and development and how a
controlled substance
is brought in and out of inventory in
order to
actually be able to do research both
from the cost
and commercial elements and also the
regulatory environment
there is a time pressure that exists in
order to
build a legal ecosystem and industry
this is mainly because of the fact that
we are converting
from a fully black market
as of a decade ago to the future where
it's
legal and has full implementations and
standards in place
that make it so that consumers can
purchase the
products with clear knowledge and
confidence in their quality
and efficacy another element
which challenges the legal growth
side is taxes and the limited practical
room for air
not only is there startup costs
but then also while producing revenue
you have to be able to have room to make
mistakes try things out and experiment
which is also going to add time and cost
to
this legalization effort
in many situations i've heard
and also referenced the industry much
like being a river
people are going to find their way as
proven over the previous decades
to consuming cannabis but if we want to
bring this to a wider group of people
then it's going to require good
regulation
and information flows trying to just
stop cannabis now is like throwing a
rock into a rushing river
people are still going to find a way so
it's important that that's where that
time pressure comes from
in order to legalize and figure things
out in a meaningful manner
historically manufacturers have been
hindered from success
by a lot of these challenges thc
production has a difficult and lengthy
road to getting licensed
set up and operating and with industrial
hemp grown for cbd
with no fda approval for any end
products other than
epidiolex and anti-seizure medicine
cbd has no nutritional or approved
medicinal application and so that has
put strains
on the downstream market to actually get
the product to consumers
there really is no alternative to
supporting current industry participants
but one of the ways that we can help
bring those participants
to a higher level is the sharing of
experience and lessons learned
there's costs and barriers to entry and
so
if we have higher churn of participants
and processors
then that means that there will be
slower advancement for
the general industry in production
resources put towards entering and
crossing those barriers of entry as
mentioned previously expensive licensing
equipment that those resources get put
into
startup costs instead of going towards
research and development
and helping to push the current product
and options
forward and advancement
we're really also have to be able to
address
scale and that's where working with the
current participants is so
market participants is so important so
that
there's mark there's markets all over
the country
and we want to make sure that they can
be served with people who are
in the local market understand their
challenges
with state level legalization this kind
of creates the borders
where people are operating inside their
own environment
but it's also important for the industry
to kind of experiment with different
directions
so with addressing scale
adsorption helps scale in the form
that it's a consistent and
it's inorganic chemistry and so it's a
consistent process
in which you're going after targeted
compounds and you're able to remove that
repeatedly which is going to help with
standardization
and creating of quality consistent
product
some of the ways that absorption
processes are used
in line with every run like a regular
process would be
depth filtration such as lenticular
filtration
meant for high flow absorption activity
and then there is also using
functionalized minerals
for color and heavy metals or it can
also be done as a batch process
for targeted contaminants using
compounds such as magnesium silicate for
pesticides or targeting color
capability really does support
regulation
more broad absorption more more broad
adoption
of absorptive practices is actually a
really good thing for the industry
by establishing industry norms and
standards set by general consensus of
capability
it's going to be easier to
regulate the industry or have
regulations
that are informed by the current
capabilities of what manufacturers can
consistently produce
ultimately a further advancement of
industry extraction technology is going
to lead to quality end product
quality end product would be
substantially free of contaminants
which would be a benefit to consumers
and also
in line with the objective of regulators
we're at the dawn of a new industry and
it cannot be understated enough
as of january 2020 roughly 244
000 full-time jobs are supported by the
legal cannabis industry
taking place all over the country at the
same time
how do you create an environment where
consumers are confident in what they're
buying
and the efficacy of what they're
adjusting into their bodies
imagine this a farmer or somebody with
some land
really wants to experiment with cannabis
so they look into it
they plant some seeds they want to grow
industrial hemp on their property
once you've produced an end product
what do you do with it if they could
find
easily a local extractor who could
process their flower product into
consumer packaged goods and oil
derivatives
from that growth in a compliant manner
and get those products back to the
grower so that they can sell that to
their local community
and have engagement
that's product which is tailored to
their local environment
an engagement of entrepreneurism and
also the opportunity for community
development
through self-starter and interactions of
producing a good
and creating value for those who want to
consume it
this new channel for entrepreneurism is
really exciting
and it would really be unlocked by
having a mature industry
that can support it it's very important
that there's
many participants in the manufacturing
landscape
so that technology isn't siloed
there's so many opportunities for the
functional uses
of biomass from cannabis industry
from green chemical stock to fibers
seeds proteins even organic stock
for new material sciences and it can't
be
said enough either that there's an
opportunity for significant
environmental impact
co2 sequestration land and water
heavy metal remediation and also there's
an opportunity for potential
radiological remediation utilizing
cannabis
there are still many challenges that
need to be overcome for the industry
in some ways challenges pop up that
are unexpected such as thc can even be a
contaminant
it may be interesting as why wouldn't
you want to have thc in your cbd
but there are many consumers that are
regulated
such as teachers those in the
transportation industry
military personnel who want to consume
cbd
for its benefits but they don't want to
fail drug tests for having thc show up
this is further exacerbated by the legal
definition
meaning that the plant can have less
than 0.3
thc but as you concentrate that down
you can end up with much higher levels
of thc in your cbd oil
this concentration issue makes it so
that technologies are needed in order to
be able to separate those out
today extractors and manufacturers
regularly use reverse phase
chromatography or other methods
in order to separate cbd and thc
which can be very difficult to distill
apart from each other
there's still a growing use of
absorption
processes it's a good thing for the
advancement of the industry
but testing new absorbance can be
exceedingly
expensive and also very time consuming
the process of trial and error isn't
something that can be done
endlessly and there is a risk to the oil
which is also highly valuable and
often controlled for example there's
thousands of different types of silica
gel so figuring out
what the industry needs and finding that
balance
specifically between cost and the
specification
of those goods is always going to be a
dynamic challenge
and really this challenge comes from a
mixture of economics and science
an example of a scenario recently
a company that we're working with had a
very dialed in
blend and process in order to
consistently remove
all of the target compounds that they
didn't want to have prevalent in their
oil
as soon as they took that blend to
another market
it didn't have the same effect that they
were looking for
this could be caused by different
constituents in the oil that they're
treating
environmental factors in their
processing facilities
but nonetheless this is still something
which we're learning and just barely
getting
into in widespread use
another element which is also
challenging
the advancement of the industry is the
information environment
there's intra industry competition
misinformation
and siloing of information in order to
create value
despite these things i ultimately think
that the cannabis industry has a strong
culture of innovation and collaboration
and it is one of the best ways forward
ultimately looking forward the
challenges of the cannabis industry are
almost impossible to know
definitively the capabilities of the
plant are so vast that it's going to
take
time to explore those those capabilities
and the challenges are also going to
change over time
an effective way to combat some of these
challenges
is through crowdsourcing of r d so that
the cost
and time isn't concentrated in order to
advance technology and also wider
adoption of absorptive technologies can
help support
standardization and push the envelope
for what we can do as an industry
it's absolutely critical that the
cannabis industry
continues to support the demand that's
there
so that less scrupulous routes aren't
found
and we consistently move towards a
quality
end product that people can count on
there are many challenges ahead
but i'm excited and i invite you to join
in overcoming these challenges
with the cannabis industry and bringing
in your field of study and being a
participant
thanks for your time